internet et la criminalité autrement dit
comment les escrocs et les délinquants
peuvent pirater les nouvelles
technologies réunis en séminaire des
experts et policiers ont fait le point
sur l'état de la menace que nous raconte
thierry curtet joseph baltique et la mer
se passe devant 90 policiers quelque peu
interloqué il faudra à peine dix minutes
à l'ingénieur informatique pour pirater
un ordinateur normalement protégés
piller les informations et détruire les
logiciels en passant par internet
s'exécute
le programme pirate s'est installé sur
ma machine
ils viennent d'une vingtaine de pays
sous l'égide du ministère de l'intérieur
et de la communauté européenne ils se
réunissent pour la première fois pour
juger de l'état de la menace
la criminalité en matière de nouvelles
technologies et l fantasmé ou bien réel
même ses spécialistes en sont encore à
se poser des questions par exemple on a
on a très peu de cas de fraude bancaire
est ce que vraiment les banquiers ont
des titres de protection très efficace
ils préfèrent couvrir les frais de ce
type de fraude elle pas en parler pour
une question d'image de marque on ne
sait pas
du côté des assureurs on estime que 60 à
80 % disent informatique touchant des
compagnies financières ne sont pas
déclarés à la tribune un accueil un vrai
sa spécialité les lignes téléphoniques
c'est un ancien client du commissaire
bonnefond qui l'a arrêté il ya quelques
années des accords comme ceux là sont
forcément des spécialistes et l'intérêt
c'est qu'ils apportent une vision du
problème que n'apporte pas forcément
l'institutionnel qui doit parer à ce
genre d'activité chez le leader mondial
de la carte à puce la sécurité
informatique est une deuxième nature
ici on reçoit volontiers la délégation
de policiers
car en la matière il faut confronter les
expériences dans cette nouvelle
criminalité peut parfois déconcerté
un policier à paris peut très bien qui
c'était un délinquant à berlin qui va
effectuer des achats avec une carte
simuler qui corresponde à un compte
français et au détriment d'un
fournisseur russe ou américain contre la
délinquance sur le réseau il faut un
autre réseau de policiers qui se
connaissent parlent le même langage ce
sera selon eux la seule façon d'assurer
la sécurité sur cette nouvelle voie
publique